la mobilisation de jeudi contre la
réforme des retraites occupe le
gouvernement comme les syndicats vous
les entendrez quant aux Français
certains ont déjà peur de manquer des
sens la déclaration commune elle est
claire pas de report de l'âge légal et
pas d'augmentation de la durée des
cotisations voilà ça c'est le ciment de
cette unité syndicale et il n'y a pas
une feuille de papier à cigarette entre
nous c'est l'élément qui fait le plus
débat et c'est l'élément pour lequel on
doit le plus se mobiliser pour
convaincre moi j'ai pas le souvenir
convaincre j'ai pas le souvenir je n'ai
pas le souvenir d'une réforme des
retraites qui se soit faite facilement
évidemment qu'il faut aller discuter
avec les Français qu'il faut aller
expliquer les choses ou alors il faut
dire la vérité aux Français il faut leur
dire qu'on va changer de système qu'on
va aller vers un système qui est plus un
système de solidarité
intergénérationnelle qui est notre
modèle et auquel nous croyons mais qui
serait demain un système par
capitalisation qui favoriserait ceux qui
auront les moyens de mettre de côté
chaque mois nous partons avec la
première ministre une réforme dont nous
sommes convaincus à la fois de la et je
ne reviens pas sur les questions
d'équilibre financiers et de la justice
parce que sur les carrières longues la
pénibilité les seigneurs le niveau
minimum de pension ne faisons des choses
ce qu'on a annoncé c'est que c'est plus
65 ans c'est 64 et que la retraite
minimum a 1200 euros ça sera aussi pour
les retraités françaises ont voté pour
cette réforme là ce n'est pas ce que
j'ai dit Sonia Mabrouk parce que je dis
c'est que on ne découvre pas aujourd'hui
ce sujet ils mettent le feu de manière
parfaitement consciente au pays et donc
ils assument
les conséquences de cette décision
politique chaque fois qu'on gagne un an
d'espérance de vie il faut travailler 18
mois de plus dans quelle société on vit
donc le progrès social c'est pas ça on
va pas revenir au droit du travail ou au
non droit du travail du temps de la
révolution industrielle je suis désolé
non non il y a il y a des oui tu pourras
dire dis moi aussi tu veux donc oui il y
a tous les ingrédients pour que cette
mobilisation soit très très forte numéro
1 du Parti communiste dit aujourd'hui
dans dans Le Parisien soyons un million
ce serait
je pense qu'on peut on peut être plus
j'ai pas de boule de cristal et je ne
fais pas la météo du dialogue social
vous attendez à quoi donc je ne sais pas
je ne sais pas je dis juste que les
organisations syndicales ont une
légitimité lorsqu'elles appellent à la
grève ou à la manifestation c'est un
droit que tout le monde le reconnaît je
souhaite que ça ne se traduise pas par
des blocages du pays
excusez-moi
qui pourront toujours aller manifester
s'agiter comme le fait monsieur Martinez
et les autres responsables syndicaux il
n'en demeure pas moins qu'ils sont
responsables de l'élection d'Emmanuel
Macron ils sont donc directement
responsables de la mise en oeuvre de
cette réforme des retraites ce genre de
soutien n'en a pas besoin et puis vous
savez aussi que nous n'avons pas les
mêmes valeurs que ce parti
anti-immigré et partir racistes et donc
vous savez aussi Philippe Martinez que
42% des ouvriers ont voté Marine Le Pen
à l'élection présidentielle quel est le
rapport je considère pas du tout les
syndicats comme des emmerdeurs
parfois
ils prennent des décisions que je peux
pas approuver ce qui s'est passé à Noël
avec le blocage des trains et qui est
empêchait un très grand nombre de gens
et de gens seuls
de
d'aller voir leur famille j'ai trouvé
que ça n'était pas juste cette semaine
il s'est excusé il a demandé pardon à la
communauté à la communauté juive
et vous ça vous fait marrer vous pensez
de la gueule du monde maintenant je ne
pense pas que ce soit vrai mais non mais
ça fait partie oui mais ça fait partie
de la vie le pardon il faut accepter le
pardon des vrais bien sûr mais comment
tu sais qu'il est faux et il a raison
les supporters sont en colère et ils
l'ont fait savoir hier soir avec des
banderoles en tribune une chèvre je vous
laisse deviner le message celui-ci est
plus clair le grenier Karl Toko et CAMBI
a été hué insulté par certains
supporters ce qui a provoqué cette
réaction
je préfère qu'ils disent pardon puis
après on verra bah oui et si après il
dit c'était une blague et ben après il
aurait dû faire une blague et puis c'est
tout